what about when you see them on the
street and they're you know doing that
impossible i protect the bag
i'm not leaving the house what would you
what would you do if you oh actually
question what would you do if you were
on the street you saw your girl like she
said hi to him and didn't pretend he
didn't existed with that right then it's
done there's many other 22s out there
i thought you were the one
i thought you were the one yeah i'm
saying we bring it in what if scenarios
are yeah
so then she's gone if she if she still
talks
but if you say you're the one and she's
been alpha widowed and she approaches
the dude that alpha widowed her no but
now you're bringing the analogy of her
getting off with it it never happened to
me but i'm saying if we if for this
purpose of the scenario it did then yeah
it's done in it yeah because it means
there's still an opening so an alpha
widow okay
i don't have the definition pulled up
but an alpha widow basically is like
if a girl is a five or a six right most
people are average so most girls five
let's say five she sleeps with a guy
that's an eight
she falls in love with this man that's
why you always hear like girls in
situation chips like they seem to be
more common than relationships these
days
and the reason is it's because a small
percentage of men are sleeping with all
the girls
and so the girl is so in love with that
guy that no other guy can compare
so it doesn't matter who she dates after
they can't beat that guy that's why rola
tamassi says and you're kind of right
with what you were saying it's not about
the number it's about the number of
alphas so if like our girls only slept
with five dudes but one of them is
michael b jordan like it's cooked she's
done
she's done
she's done four and like same with same
with sierra like maybe you know maybe
she only slept with five but they're all
rappers
future like what are you going to beat
future
and so it's basically like some guys say
it's
some some people say it's or the girl
views that as the best she could do like
she can never do better and so then when
she starts aging out of the dating
market when the attention's starting to
go she looks around and grabs the first
guy she can that's willing to marry her
and then she looks at him as less and
doesn't respect him
because she thinks oh i could have done
better i should be with that guy
okay have you seen that dynamic
no
never
no okay sorry
you've never had a girl that's like
afraid like that can't get over her ex
oh no yeah absolutely so in a way that
that that's an alpha widow oh an alpha
widow like the girl that that is always
talking about that one guy acts she
hates him
like that's definitely an alpha we're
doing for me exactly yeah
so it's such a complex thing to boil
down to he's an alpha
i mean okay the alpha the alpha term i
don't love and it's funny before i was
in this space i i sort of hated that
term too
because it's just like it it
who's alpha right but it doesn't matter
it's the most alpha guy that she can get
so it's the best that she can do it may
not be that he's the guy that walks in
terms of strength intellect financial
like many different things men bring
different things to the table and you
could i could date a really really
strong
man that's in a gang and i know you
protect me or i could date a man that's
really really really rich
or i could date a man that has very high
intellect
like
so so it goes contextual yeah yeah and
so it goes down to money muscles game
and frame
what is so so frame is basically
you're entering his frame and he's not
entering yours so frame in a way is
masculinity
i don't still understand um okay so if
you work for somebody
it it's
stepping into that yes yes versus him
stepping in so it's like leadership
for like holding frame is when you
when you like make fun of it so a way of
girls will do a [ __ ] test that's what
they call it is they'll make fun of a
guy a little bit and you want you don't
know this consciously but you're
watching to see how he reacts does he
make fun of you back does he kind of
like play into it or does he does he
like get offended and if he gets
offended that's him falling into your
frame
because
he's thinking he's miss
had to do this historically because we
had to make sure the guy could protect
us okay yeah and so that's why if a guy
kind of makes fun of you like comes up
to you and he's like what's wrong with
that you're like
like
you're kind of more interested right but
it's it's him because you're going into
his frame okay
and so and it's what the girl values so
like i i
was really involved in a church when i
lived in milwaukee and all the girls
there was relationship with god so they
wanted like that was the most alpha guy
they could get had the closest
relationship with god it was kind of
that's what i was thinking of when you
were talking about the different
communities was the guys there that got
all the girls probably would be viewed
as beta in the normal world but they but
they were getting the virgins
which which is the ideal right it's not
it's not like that's not funny i think i
think just to add to your point right
perception is everything from the
woman's standpoint if she perceives the
man
as an alpha then that's all that really
matters it doesn't matter if her friends
don't see amazon yeah it's all about her
so she she would be alpha widowed by
that man because she perceived him as an
author as an owner yeah and that the
point comes down to women actually want
men speaking to the mic women actually
want men better than them that doesn't
necessarily mean that the man is better
than them but she wants to see him as
better than her yeah i get that
yeah and so that's the problem with
girls with a bad boy past is because
oftentimes she doesn't she wants that
guy because
hate and love are very close but aren't
these 20 that are getting all the women
bad boys
no not at all i wouldn't say all some
some are i mean so the baiters are in
the twenty percent or is it mean like
the alphas and they're getting all the
women and then the women are ruined and
then they're like oh we're gonna go to
the other eighty percent sort of i mean
to be an alpha doesn't mean that you're
a bad boy like someone like for example
let's say [ __ ]
i don't know joe biden
yeah yeah i'd say my older brother's an
alpha but he's like really geeky yeah
but he's a high value man
loads of women would understand throw
themselves at him yeah it's just
basically that women women
i think they'd kill him if they shoot
themselves smash it
in the dirt
someone on twitter the other day was
like oh my gosh joe biden is such a good
looking man i would go to him and i
would move to him and someone was like
yeah i want my student's loan paid off
too but that's not the way to do it girl
yeah but
in the same way but if you show joe
biden to like loads of girls from
venezuela who are from the slums you'll
be like yeah i'm on it yeah but that
wouldn't be
because i honestly i think everything
starts with looks
because i i think that if you want a
girl to genuinely desire you like you
have to be somewhat similar on the looks
level
yeah because if if a dude is like okay
if you if you
multi-millionaire tomorrow right or
let's say let's say fat guy right
multi-millionaire tomorrow he can get a
girl it's an eight nine or ten but she's
just with him for the money so it's not
like that genuine desire like like so a
lot of attractions chemical
so so women can women can smell a
t-shirt and see which guy they'd be the
most attracted to so
it's
you know it's not it's not that genuine
desire i don't know you say that but it
all depends on
where skewed in terms of your brain of
thinking what you find attractive like
is the most attractive thing to you is